Donc, je sais qu'il y a certaines personnes qui sont en train de nous joindre en cours de route dans cette série d'études.
Et donc, c'est toujours très important de faire une petite révision de ce qu'on a déjà traversé,
notamment car si, par exemple, nous avons déjà croisé des conceptions bibliques, des expressions bibliques, des termes bibliques,
ou même des termes théologiques, des termes utilisés au long de l'histoire de l'Église et dans toutes les sociétés occidentales,
mais qu'aujourd'hui, nous sentons un peu plus d'allergie envers certains termes.
Et même certaines églises, parfois, veulent changer les expressions.
Donc, par exemple, elles vont se dire l'expression « péché » un peu démodée.
On vit dans une génération qui a tellement été imprégnée par une autre perspective du problème de l'homme.
Et on voit plutôt les problèmes de l'homme, par exemple, comme une question des carences, des manques d'affirmation.
Ce n'est pas qu'ils soient mauvais, c'est juste qu'il y a quelque chose qui manque encore.
Peut-être un peu plus d'éducation, peut-être un peu plus d'affirmation, un peu plus des valeurs de soi, l'estime de soi, etc.
Et on devient un peu réfratère à certaines conceptions.
Ce n'est pas qu'on n'ait pas la capacité de comprendre les termes, de connaître ou reconnaître les termes.
Ça montre plutôt combien écartés nous sommes de l'explication biblique du problème de l'homme.
Et donc, si l'expression comme « les péchés », qui dans son essence est tout simplement « raté la cible »,
qui a une explication beaucoup plus profonde, mais qui essentiellement est tellement simple
que tous les êtres humains ont la capacité de comprendre.
Et quelque part, c'est un problème évident chez chaque être humain.
Car tous les êtres humains, même si dans l'extérieur, en cherchant à cautériser la conscience,
on va parfois mettre en question les paramètres des dieux qu'il a révélés dans sa parole,
par exemple les dix commandements, ou ce qui doit encadrer nos relations en tant qu'être humain,
homme et femme, etc.
Cela n'est pas suffisant pour effacer l'effet que tous les êtres humains
sont en train de lutter contre leur propre conscience.
Car selon nos propres standards de la vie qu'on devrait vivre,
on est tous en déçà de la réalité de notre conscience.
Les manques de paix qui caractérisent l'humanité,
elle est notamment à cause du fait qu'on est toujours en train de rater,
même les paramètres très tordus et cautérisés de notre propre conscience.
Et c'est clair qu'à la mesure où tout être humain est exposé avec clarté aux paramètres des dieux,
comme nous sommes tous des créatures des dieux,
nous sommes progressivement moins capables de nous cacher de la vérité.
C'est-à-dire que tous les êtres humains ont la capacité de raisonner,
de correspondre à une exposition claire de la vérité des dieux.
Et donc, on n'a pas le choix pour notre propre bien,
car nous sommes véritablement intéressés dans un diagnostic précis de notre condition.
On veut plutôt que, oui, on restaure les conceptions bibliques de ce qui est,
les péchés, la conception de la chute,
car il n'y a aucun autre mot qui pourrait décrire
de manière peut-être plus précise ce que se passe avec l'être humain.
La manière dont la Bible va décrire, par exemple,
notre séparation des dieux, notre rébellion contre Dieu,
les débuts de la mort chez l'être humain,
c'est une chute.
Dans quel sens ?
Car avant de nous présenter la manière dont nous,
nous sommes rebellés contre Dieu,
et la manière dont nous,
nous sommes mis dans cette condition
des dégradations, des corruptions,
c'est juste après de nous avoir présenté
l'état sublime et élevé dans lequel Dieu nous a créés.
Donc si on a le manque de félicité et de satisfaction
qui est présent chez tous les êtres humains,
insatiable,
c'est car nous sommes devant un indice
qu'un jour on était satisfait.
Si nous avons des crises morales,
c'est pour indiquer qu'un jour,
c'est qu'exige la conscience,
on était capable de les faire.
Si nous avons des aspirations pour une société parfaite,
pour être délivré de la maladie,
de l'enveillissement,
ces choses-là,
c'est car un jour on n'a pas créé pour être dégradé,
fini.
Et donc si nous trouvons cette soif
qui caractérise les principaux crises existentielles
dans l'histoire de l'humanité,
de la philosophie même,
nous sommes devant des aspirations
qui ont une raison d'être
et qui pointent envers un état parfait.
Sauf que la réalité,
c'est que personne n'arrive à vivre
à la hauteur de ses aspirations.
L'explication biblique fait du sens.
Nous avons tombé,
à chute.
On a été créé dans une position si élevée
et on n'a pas évolué.
Au contraire.
C'est l'opposé de la théorie de l'évolution
qui veut expliquer, par exemple,
la condition des l'homme notre aujourd'hui
comme les restes de nos instants animaux.
Et c'est beaucoup plus facile
pour une conscience troublée
de chercher à croire
que je ne suis pas devant un péché,
quelque chose qui me responsabilise
et qui me coupabilise.
Je préfère être plutôt devant
les restes
d'un être humain qui est encore en évolution.
Des restes animaux.
Et donc ça apporte beaucoup de troubles,
mais c'est juste pour vous expliquer
que la terminologie biblique,
elle est très importante.
La terminologie
qu'on a adoptée historiquement aussi,
même lorsque les termes ne sont pas bibliques,
mais quand on l'explique,
quand on fait les choix de les utiliser,
c'est pour décrire quelque chose
qui est précise dans la parole de Dieu.
Donc là,
le sixième chapitre
de la confession de foi,
c'est à propos de la chute de l'homme,
les péchés
et son châtiment.
Et châtiment,
c'est aussi un mot un peu démodé.
Car on est dans une génération
qui déjà n'ose même pas dire
« tu as tort ».
Et encore pire,
c'est mauvais
ou c'est incorrect.
Le maximum que j'entends parler
dans les crèches
pour mes enfants,
c'est
qu'on n'est pas d'accord.
c'est interdit.
Mais on a beau fait le travail
de vider
même du vocabulaire social
tout indice
des coupabilisations
de l'être humain.
Et s'il n'y a pas
la notion des responsabilités
et coupabilisations,
il n'y a pas
les bons diagnostics,
on ne cherche pas
les bons médicaments
et les bons traitements.
Et donc,
pour revenir
sur ce qu'on a considéré
jusqu'ici,
la première chose
qu'on a considérée,
c'est la relation
entre cette doctrine,
pourquoi elle est placée,
à la position
qu'elle est placée,
l'ordre.
Et donc,
la première chose
qu'on a étudiée,
c'était notamment
la Bible.
Pourquoi nous pouvons
nous fier à la Bible ?
On a considéré
tous les arguments bibliques
ou les principaux arguments bibliques
pour nous convaincre
que dans un monde,
dans un univers
où l'évidence des dieux
est affichée pour tous,
et que ça fasse partie
de toute la race humaine
un phénomène religieux,
une quête pour Dieu
et qu'on soit devant
une pluralité
des religions
ou des philosophies,
les visions des mondes
qui, à la fin des comptes,
deviennent aussi des religions,
tout ce qui n'est pas
prouvé par la science
devient une théorie
que les personnes
doivent croire
et la réalité,
c'est que devant
toutes ces possibilités
de l'existence des dieux
ou non-existence des dieux
dans la compréhension
des êtres humains,
on serait complètement perdu
si on était livré
tout simplement
à la limitation
de nos interprétations
à propos de qui est Dieu
et de comment nous rapporter
à lui,
surtout dans une condition
de corruption.
Donc,
les besoins impératifs,
c'est que si on veut
avoir une certitude
par rapport à Dieu,
c'est que Dieu lui-même
se révèle
et que Dieu lui-même
d'une manière concrète
et inchangeable
pour qu'on puisse avoir
une base de connaissances
d'autorité
dans lesquelles
nous puissions trouver
la vérité à propos de Dieu.
Et on a considéré,
donc nous serions devant
plusieurs possibilités
car plusieurs religions
veulent réclamer
l'autorité
de leurs livres sacrés,
mais on a fait
un bon travail,
un long travail
pour considérer
pourquoi la Bible,
elle est unique
dans ce sens-là.
Pourquoi c'est les livres
véritablement inspirés.
Entre autres choses,
ce qui va lier un peu
avec les thèmes d'aujourd'hui,
c'est cette notion
que la Bible a,
ou cette capacité
que la Bible a
d'expliquer la réalité
avec un niveau
de satisfaction
incomparable.
Par exemple,
les diagnostics bibliques
pour l'homme,
comme j'espère qu'on voit
et qu'on constate,
ou les diagnostics bibliques
pour ce que l'homme est
en tant que créature
à l'image des dieux,
c'est les sommets
de l'anthropologie
qu'on puisse avoir.
C'est impossible de mieux
comprendre l'être humain
ailleurs.
Et donc,
c'est juste un indice,
une des évidences
par rapport à la Bible,
mais l'importance
d'avoir un livre base
pour que vous ne soyez pas
dans la dépendance
de l'autorité du pasteur,
du prêtre,
de l'Église,
mais que l'Église elle-même
et les prêtres
et les pasteurs
soient soumises
à cette base d'autorité
infaillible.
Et donc,
la Bible est la base d'autorité
pour nous
et la base des connaissances
des dieux.
Quel est le contenu principal
de la Bible ?
C'est Dieu lui-même.
Qui Dieu est
dans sa beauté,
dans sa gloire,
dans ses perfections.
Et c'est la deuxième doctrine
qu'on a considérée.
Pour qu'on n'ait pas
des doutes
par rapport
aux excellences
des dieux
lorsqu'on s'approchera
des questions
théologiques
et des crises existentielles
qui, parfois,
à cause de notre condition
misérables,
nous font douter
de l'amour des dieux,
de la bonté des dieux,
de la toute-puissance des dieux.
Car si Dieu est Dieu,
pourquoi les mâles ?
Et donc,
on commence par ce que
la Bible enseigne
de manière très explicite
à propos des dieux.
Ensuite,
on a passé à considérer
non seulement
qui Dieu est
dans l'excellence
et la beauté
de sa gloire,
mais les œuvres
des dieux.
Et donc,
Dieu,
en tant qu'omniscient,
tout-puissant,
rien ne peut frustrer
à ses plans
et ses plans sont parfaits.
Donc,
on a considéré
la troisième doctrine,
la doctrine sur
les décrets éternels
des dieux
dans les singuliers
car Dieu acquéent
un plan A.
Tout est en train
de se passer
exactement de la manière
dont Dieu a planifié.
Ses plans sont parfaits.
Et bien sûr
qu'il s'apporte
une tension
par rapport
à la manière
dont il a créé
des êtres
responsables
et libres
et cette tension
doit nous accompagner
pour toujours.
car elle est
une réalité inévitable.
Dieu est 100% souverain,
nous sommes 100% responsables,
nous avons la responsabilité
et donc dans la souveraineté
de Dieu
il a planifié
des choses
qui auront lieu
par l'intermède
de la responsabilité
et de la libre agence
des êtres humains.
Et donc,
ça nous a apporté
dans la direction
de la doctrine
de la création
de l'homme.
la doctrine
de la création
de l'homme.
Donc,
Dieu a créé
toutes les choses,
ensuite il a mis en marche
et ce qui était
au sommet
de la doctrine
de la création,
c'était la création
de l'homme
à l'image de Dieu.
Donc,
on a fait
un beau dialogue
avec la propagande
plus récente
de la promotion
majoritaire
de la théorie
de l'évolution
qui a eu
un impact
non seulement
dans la compréhension
des origines
mais qui a eu
un impact énorme
dans la société
par rapport
aux valeurs.
Car si nous avons
comme origine
une énergie
qui ne pense pas,
qui a tout simplement
généré par explosion
tout ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui,
la réalité
c'est qu'en ayant
pour origine
un être
qui n'est pas personnel
qui n'a pas
des sentiments
nous sommes tombés
en tant que génération
surtout
post-relativiste
en Europe
dans les nihilismes.
On doit nier
cette aspiration
pour l'existence
ça n'a pas de sens
cette aspiration
pour une signification
on doit nier
même la moralité
on va tout réduire
à la machine
de la civilité
qui en soi-même
n'aurait pas d'essence
en tant que valeur
car ça ne fait pas
de sens de parler
des valeurs
et des moralités
si l'origine
de tout ça
c'est une énergie
qui ne pense pas
qui n'a pas de sentiment
donc l'être humain
tombe dans ce que
certains philosophes
appellent
les cynismes
philosophiques
c'est de vivre
la vie
comme s'il y avait
une signification
tout en affirmant
qu'il n'y a pas
de signification
donc les relativismes
les nihilismes
les existentialismes
et la réalité
c'est que
non seulement
la science
n'est pas pour
cette théorie
comme la science
est beaucoup plus
pour
et on a bien
considéré
les récits bibliques
à propos de la création
et donc on a considéré
l'importance
d'interpréter
de manière historique
et littérale
Genèse
et on a même
fait un dialogue
avec les évidences
scientifiques
qui corroborent
la manière biblique
de présenter les choses
donc les sommets
de la création
c'est l'homme
créé à l'image
de Dieu
c'est qui justifie
et explique
toutes ces aspirations
qu'on a
pour la noblesse
de l'homme
pour la moralité
parfaite
pour les relations
parfaites
d'amour
pour une conduite
morale
parfaite
et pour cette
relation avec Dieu
car on n'est pas
satisfait
avec toute bonne chose
que Dieu crée
car Dieu nous a créés
surtout pour lui-même
et donc
on a considéré
la doctrine
de la providence
c'est le fait
que Dieu
non seulement
a mis en marche
toutes les choses
mais qu'il soutient
qu'il gouverne l'histoire
et qu'il gouverne
l'histoire
entre autres choses
à travers
la libre agence
des êtres responsables
ça c'est très important
cette tension
doit être toujours
permanente dans nos têtes
car pour plus
que Dieu soit
100% souverain
de manière mystérieuse
pour nous
il a déterminé
que les choses
se passeraient
par la réalité
de la responsabilité
des êtres libres
et c'est très important
de nous rappeler
de tous ces principes
car
s'il y a
une doctrine
surtout dans notre condition
corrompue
des victimisations
et de l'idolâtrie
des soi
l'évangile
du développement personnel
va aussi dans sa direction
mais la réalité
c'est que
l'idolâtrie du soi
quand on contemple
les récits bibliques
de la chute
de l'homme
nos premiers
instants
victimistes
c'est de mettre
Dieu en question
pourquoi a-t-il
permis
comment il a pu
laisser
les péchés
rentrer
pourquoi il n'a pas
empêché
Satan
dans la tentation
et on oublie
l'emphase
biblique
très généreuse
par rapport
à notre condition
des béatitudes
originales
et le fait
que Dieu
nous a mis
et nous a placés
malgré notre
total manque
d'importance
dans une position
très élevée
l'homme
est appelé
âme vivante
dans quel contexte
car d'abord
il a été fait
de la poussière
de la terre
Adam
qui signifie
poussière
nous sommes
de la poussière
et le Saint-Esprit
des dieux
Dieu lui-même
nous a rempli
des significations
des personnalités
des vies
des noblesse
et il nous a placés
dans un paradis
très généreux
donc lorsque nous
nous rébellons
contre Dieu
contre sa parole
contre son amour
contre sa générosité
la dernière chose
qu'on aurait aimé
oser mettre en question
c'est la justice
des dieux
la bonté des dieux
la générosité
des dieux
etc.
et voilà pourquoi
cet ordre
elle est très importante
quand on organise
notre compréhension
biblique
non seulement
cet ordre
est importante
dans un niveau
théologique
c'est-à-dire
les doctrines
dans notre confession
mais
notamment
elles sont
très importantes
dans
l'implication
théologique
car
c'est les mêmes
ordres
qu'on va retrouver
dans la narrative
biblique
de l'histoire
et donc
c'est très important
pour nous
de comprendre
que
cet ordre
et cette relation
entre les vérités
bibliques
et l'importance
aussi qu'elles soient
littérales
et historiques
pour que nous
arrivions
à la bonne attitude
quand on s'approche
de la chute de l'homme
pour ne pas oser
mettre Dieu en question
et pour arriver
avec humilité
pour écouter
les diagnoses
bibliques
afin de trouver
la bonne solution
et donc
en ayant faire
ce résumé
par rapport
à l'ordre
des choses
qu'on a considérées
on a
parlé un petit peu
de l'importance
ou de la pertinence
de cette doctrine
donc particulièrement
la doctrine
à propos de l'homme
de la chute de l'homme
car
si
quand on considère
la création de l'homme
à l'image de Dieu
on est devant
une explication positive
de notre état original
et ça nous fait
comprendre aussi
les bonnes aspirations
qu'on a pour la vie
nous savons
que nous ne sommes pas
en train de vivre
cette réalité
cette plénitude
d'aujourd'hui
donc l'une des plus
grandes difficultés
pour les pensées
les plus philosophiques
de nos jours
y compris
je vous ai évoqué déjà
la question de cet homme
qui a gagné
les prix Nobel
qui disait
qu'il ne pourrait pas
croire à l'évangile
car il voyait
que l'être humain
était un puzzle
dans ce sens là
il a des aspirations
qu'il n'arrive jamais
à remplir
des aspirations
pour une moralité parfaite
par exemple
pour la satisfaction pleine
pour l'infinitude
lorsqu'il est fini
et donc
si Dieu a créé
l'homme tel qu'il est
Dieu a inséré
au-dedans de l'homme
une crise
infinie
c'est un Dieu
sarcastique
quelque part
le problème
c'est que ces diagnostics
là ne prennent pas
en considération
ils prennent en considération
ce que l'homme
est aujourd'hui
mais ne prennent pas
en considération
le fait qu'il y a eu
une discontinuité
dans l'histoire
de l'humanité
donc l'anthropologie
biblique
elle nous aide
à comprendre
nos aspirations
c'est qu'on a été
un jour
paradis perdu
et paradis
récupéré
et donc dans le sens
où nous sommes
devant
lorsqu'on est devant
l'évangile
on est devant
la principale quête
de l'humanité
donc nous ne pouvons
pas comprendre
l'homme tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui
mais nous ne pouvons
pas comprendre
non plus
cette relation
entre l'homme
et son environnement
on sait que
non seulement
nous sommes en train
d'être responsables
pour la dégradation
de cet univers
duquel nous dépendons
pour vivre
mais c'est intéressant
aussi de remarquer
que cet univers
à plusieurs reprises
se manifeste
contre nous
les menaces
des animaux
des catastrophes
etc
et quel est
les diagnostics
bibliques
c'est pas que
Dieu les a créés
comme ça
contre nous
c'est que nous
on était
les entendants
de toute la création
la création
était là
pour maximiser
notre capacité
de glorifier Dieu
de les cultiver
de les garder
de les ordonner
mais nous
à cause
de notre rébellion
on a rendu
cet univers
otage
et là
nous travaillons
presque contre
cet univers
contre nous
et donc c'est à partir
de là
qu'on comprend aussi
l'état
du monde
actuel
les crises
internes
de l'homme
les crises
externes
de l'homme
la précision
de l'explication
publique
pour notre
diagnostic
c'est la seule
capable d'expliquer
l'homme tel qu'il est
de manière satisfatoire
ce n'est pas
des explications
qu'on trouve
dans la psychologie
dans la psychanalyse
on ne les trouve pas
non plus
dans la médecine
ni dans la sociologie
ni dans la philosophie
ni dans la civilité
ni dans la politique
et ni même
dans l'apologétique
et c'est intéressant
car
les implications
de cette pertinence
se portent aussi
envers
la compréhension
de l'évangile
si on ne comprend pas
la chute de l'homme
par cette représentation
fédérale d'Adam
on ne peut pas
comprendre
les saluts de l'homme
par la représentation
du Christ
il faut qu'on avance
et donc
si la corruption
de l'homme
est évidente
de manière universelle
les diagnostics
qu'on peut trouver
entre les êtres humains
ne l'est pas
ils sont toujours
insuffisants
je vous ai déjà dit
certains vont présenter
ces principes
des dualismes éternels
comme si ça faisait partie
de la réalité
les biens contre les mals
et même au-dedans
de l'homme
d'autres vont
comme j'ai déjà dit
faire écours
à cette théorie
de l'évolution
où ne parlons pas
un terme moraux absolus
mais c'est tout
tout simplement
ce qui manque
à l'être humain
et ces théories
comportamentales
qui vont aller
plus ou moins
dans la même direction
où les péchés
sont vus
tout simplement
comme l'absence
de certaines qualités
positives
ou comme une sorte
de résistance
qui a été placée
peut-être par la divinité
pour qu'on puisse
évoluer quelque part
en surmontant
ces challenges
et donc
il faut qu'on
reconnaisse
la totale nécessité
et la totale
efficacité
du récit biblique
et ce qu'on va
passer à faire
à partir de là
donc la première chose
qu'on va faire
avant de considérer
la confession
des fois
en elle-même
qui va nous présenter
la chute
d'une manière
plus doctrinaire
par des déclarations
plus concises
plus précises
j'espère
qu'on puisse avoir
une expérience
avec les textes
bibliques directs
on va tout simplement
lire Genèse
et on va lire Genèse
avec un abordage
historique littéral
ok
donc c'est impératif
qu'on le fasse
et j'espère
qu'à la mesure
où on le fait
ça soit encore plus clair
pourquoi
nous avons tellement besoin
de faire face
à cet épisode
comme quelque chose
de littéral
d'historique
et pas comme tout simplement
un mythe
pas comme tout simplement
une parabole
ou des symboles
donc
pourquoi
c'est impératif
d'aborder
Genèse
comme histoire
donc déjà
car
dans les traditions
les plus conservatrices
d'entre les juifs
ça a été toujours
le cas
donc même
ils prennent
les termes Genèse
pour décrire commencement
et c'est pour se référer
notamment au commencement
c'est pas un commencement
symbolique
qui aurait pu suggérer
par exemple
des heures
des jours
ou des choses comme ça
car pour eux
c'était les commencements
et commencement
a aussi une implication
historique
surtout pour les juifs
car
il est
plein des généalogies
et il y a
plein de références
par rapport
à des lieux géographiques
reconnaissables
parfois même jusqu'aujourd'hui
on voit les dates
on voit les lieux géographiques
et c'est là
depuis Genèse
chapitre 1 à 3
comme on verra bientôt
donc les lieux
la question
d'une interprétation
historique
et littérale
des Genèse
commence par
tout simplement
l'encadrement
littéral
des Genèse
donc
aucun indice
direct
dans les textes
ne peut suggérer
une interprétation
allégorique
et le problème
c'est que
le deuxième argument
c'est
la cohérence
contextuelle
directe
donc si
je ne traite pas
les premiers versets
en Asset
comme on vient de lire
comme littéral
comment je peux traiter
les versets 14 et 15
qui parlent de la
conséquence de la chute
qui deviendra
pour tous les restes
de la Bible
comme un événement
historique
que l'Écrit
lui-même
doit prendre la chair
et venir et faire
une œuvre historique
afin de renverser
et afin d'accomplir
la promesse
qui est faite
en Genèse
chapitre 3
du descendant
de la femme
d'Ève
viendra un
qui va écraser
la tête du serpent
donc quand est-ce
que nous-mêmes
de manière très arbitraire
on va décider
ici c'est allégorie
ici c'est pas allégorie
ici c'est mythe
ici c'est histoire
c'est pas nous de les faire
par une question
des cohérences
immédiates
dans les contextes
du texte
nous savons
que tous les chrétiens
orthodoxes
conservateurs
vont défendre
cette chute
avec ses conséquences
comme quelque chose
d'historique
car Christ vient
accomplir quelque chose
pour la renverser
et pourquoi
on va douter
du serpent par exemple
ou de l'arbre
etc.
ça c'est une question
c'est un fait historique
aussi car
à cause d'une cohérence
dans la théologie
biblique
donc
nier
que cette partie-là
est une partie historique
c'est dénier
une grande partie
de la Bible
car tout l'enseignement
biblique
concernant l'homme
pour expliquer
les péchés lui-même
la corruption
originale
le fait
qu'on a été
retrouvé
en Adam
lorsqu'il a péché
de manière fédérale
donc
tous les restes
de la Bible
c'est quelque part
un rapport
direct
envers
ce qui se passe
dans Genèse
il faut
rejeter
toute la Bible
si on veut
rejeter
Genèse
c'est aussi
impératif
qu'on fasse
une lecture littérale
historique
à cause d'une cohérence
dans la théologie
systématique
donc là
on revient
aux doctrines
et la confession
qu'est-ce que je veux dire
par théologie
systématique
par exemple
on a étudié
la doctrine
de la création
plus tard
on va étudier
la doctrine
du salut
c'est quoi ça
on va rassembler
plusieurs textes bibliques
qui parlent à propos
de ces thèmes
de salut
et on va se demander
comment les saluts
ont lieu
dans la vie de l'homme
et là
la réponse
qu'on va donner
c'est plus ou moins
comme ça
c'est qu'est par la foi
en Jésus seul
c'est répentance
et foi
à la conversion
d'où on a tiré ça
de la Bible
sauf que dans
les connexions
entre les doctrines
bibliques
par exemple
en Rome
en chapitre 5
Jésus est appelé
les nouvelles Adam
car il est notre
représentant légal
devant les tribunaux
des dieux
pour renverser
les châtiments
qui arrivent
sur notre race
à cause
de notre premier
représentant légal
Adam
et donc
tout est lié
quand on essaye
d'organiser
les doctrines bibliques
et donc
si j'ai ni
la chute
ou les péchés
originales
j'essaierai
en train de nier
ces autres choses
aussi
il y aura toujours
la cohérence
de la théologie
systématique
mais aussi
la cohérence
historique
donc toutes
les conséquences
qui ont suivi
cette description
donc là
on revient
à la capacité
du récit
biblique
de la chute
de décrire
la chute
d'une manière
tellement
inspirée
et puissante
que nous pouvons
comprendre
à chaque fois
qu'on tombe
dans un péché
comment nous sommes
rapportés
à cette chute
initiale
comment la nature
du péché
est la même
jusqu'à aujourd'hui
et comment ça a la capacité
de nous expliquer
et de donner du sens
à cette bataille
constante qu'on a
contre la chair
et donc l'histoire
prouve
que cette chute
est réelle
et c'est intéressant
aussi de remarquer
une question
de cohérence
tout simplement
d'interprétation
donc si une partie
des généalistes
est un fait historique
l'ensemble sera
c'est la question
arbitraire
mais aussi
une question
de cohérence
tout simplement
avec la notion
des fois
dans les sources naturelles
si je crois
en Dieu
et si je crois
dans un être
qui est la Bible
décrit comme
le diable
qui est actif
réel
puissant
comme on a étudié
aussi
quand on a étudié
la création
on a étudié
les anges
et donc
si j'ai la foi
pour croire
dans les sources naturelles
qu'est-ce qui peut
m'empêcher
de croire
dans tous les sources naturelles
que la Bible évoque
quelle serait
la difficulté
de croire
à la création
à partir de rien
de croire
à la résurrection
du Christ
et de ne pas croire
dans la capacité
d'un être spirituel
très puissant
de faire osage
d'un animal
pour se communiquer
dans la tentation
et donc
la plus importante
ou les plus importants
des arguments
c'est la cohérence
tout simplement
des critères
d'interprétation
intra-bibliques
qu'est-ce que je dis
para
c'est que
quand on prend
les passages bibliques
dans les nouveaux testaments
et même dans l'ancien testament
à plusieurs reprises
ils vont faire
recours
à l'explication
du problème
original
de l'homme
et du salut
en interprétant
de manière littérale
et historique
la chute de l'homme
et donc
si les auteurs bibliques
sont inspirés
et ils prennent
pour historique
et littérale
Genèse
et la chute
particulièrement
nous devons les prendre
donc on a considéré
Job 31-33
si j'ai couvert
mes transgressions
comme Adam
en cachant mon iniquité
dans mon sang
oser 6-7
mais ils ont
comme Adam
violé l'alliance
c'est alors
ce qu'ils m'ont
été infidèles
Dieu lui-même
en faisant
l'interprétation littérale
de Genèse 3
2 Corinthiens 11-3
mais j'écran
que comme les serpents
séduisent
Ève
par la ruse
par sa ruse
ainsi vos pensées
ne se corrompent
en s'éloignant
de la simplicité
à l'égard des Christs
et 1 Timothée 2-14
et Adam
n'a pas été séduis
mais la femme séduite
s'est rendue coupable
des transgressions
et donc nous avons
plusieurs passages
qui traitent
de manière très explicite
cette interprétation
de Genèse
comme en étant
une interprétation littérale
donc pour nous
pour un chrétien
c'est pas un choix
de ne pas
interpréter
à cause de tous
ces risques
qui sont connectés
et donc nous allons
passer au texte public
et considérer
ou faire un rappel
de cette première partie
de l'exposition
ou un rappel
de l'état
des béatitudes
quelque chose
qu'on a déjà
considéré
dans la création
originale de l'homme
mais qui est
davantage importante
pour nous
pour nous rappeler
de l'encadrement
des béatitudes
avant la chute
car la Bible
elle est très intentionnelle
à nous présenter
cette réalité
donc on va revenir
à Genèse chapitre 1
soyons tous
en train de lire
ensemble la parole
de Dieu
Genèse 1
verset 26
Dieu dit
faisons l'homme
notre image
selon notre rassemblance
et qu'il domine
sur les poissons
de la mer
sur les oiseaux
du ciel
sur les bétails
sur toute la terre
et sur tous les reptiles
qui rampent
sur la terre
Dieu créa l'homme
à son image
il créa l'image
des dieux
il les créa
homme et femme
donc à nouveau
il a créé
l'homme
l'humanité
à l'image
des dieux
même valeur
avec distinction
des genres
très clairs
hommes et femmes
ok
je vous en rappelle
ensuite
Dieu les bénit
Dieu leur dit
soyez féconds
multipliez
remplissez la terre
et la sujétissez
et dominez
sur les poissons
de la mer
sur les oiseaux
du ciel
sur tout animal
qui s'émeut
sur la terre
et Dieu dit
voici je vous donne
toute herbe
portant la sémence
et qui est
sur la surface
de la terre
et tout arbre
ayant en lui
du fruit
d'arbre
et portant de la sémence
ce sera votre nourriture
et à tout animal
de la terre
à tout oiseau
du ciel
et à tout ce qui s'émeut
sur la terre
ayant en soi
un souffle de vie
je donne toute herbe
verte pour nourriture
et cela fut ainsi
Dieu vit
tout ce qu'il avait fait
et voici cela
était très bon
ainsi Dieu
il eut
pardon
en soir
et en matin
ce fut
le sixième jour
donc ici c'est
le sommet
l'apothéose
de la création
qui va être conclu
avec la création
de l'homme
le mieux
pour la fin
et l'homme
créé à l'image
de Dieu
en ayant
tout cet univers
comme
les scénarios
avec lesquels
il interagisseraient
afin
de fonctionner
comme image
des dieux sur terre
comme des petits rois
pour reproduire
l'image des dieux
sur terre
et donc ici
nous avons de manière
très claire
cette position
très élevée
il avait
la béatitude
des significations
il avait
la béatitude
d'être
donc il était créé
pour refléter
l'image des dieux
signification
béatitude d'être
il était un être
moralement parfait
et parfaitement satisfait
il avait la béatitude
des relations
avec son épouse
et il avait
cette relation
de pouvoir
correspondre
avec Dieu
réjouir
de la communion
avec Dieu
ensuite on passe
au chapitre 2
verset 2
ainsi furent achevés
les cieux
et la terre
et toute leur armée
Dieu achéva
au septième jour
son œuvre
qu'il avait
faite
et il se
reposa
au septième
jour
de toute son œuvre
qu'il avait
faite
Dieu bénit
les septième
jour
et les
sanctifia
parce qu'en
ces jours
il se
reposa
de toute
son œuvre
qu'il avait
créée
en la faisant
donc les septième
jour
ici
c'est clair
que les
repos
de Dieu
ici
n'a pas
la signification
d'un
besoin
de quelqu'un
qui est fatigué
c'est plutôt
un jour
de contemplation
et de réjouissance
c'est un jour
sacré
qu'il a séparé
pour avoir
ces jours
des communions
plus intensives
avec l'homme
avec la femme
dans cette création
parfaite
donc c'est une question
qui veut signifier
la complitude
la plénitude
de cette œuvre
créatrice
qu'il a faite
et donc l'être humain
avait la béatitude
suprême
ici
car quand on
revient sur la
restauration
des dix commandements
on revient sur
garder un jour
sur sept
pour la communion
avec Dieu
et qui renvoie
à cette notion
de satisfaire
les besoins
les plus sublimes
de l'âme
être en communion
avec Dieu
ok
ensuite
verset 7
du chapitre 2
l'éternel Dieu
forma
de la poussière
de la terre
il souffla
dans ses narines
l'homme
pardon
en souffle des vies
et l'homme
des vents
en être vivant
puis l'éternel Dieu
planta un jardin
en aidant
du côté de l'Orient
et il y mit l'homme
qui l'avait formé
l'éternel Dieu
fit pousser
du sol
des arbres
de toutes espèces
agréable à voir
et bon à manger
et l'arbre de la vie
au milieu du jardin
et l'arbre de la connaissance
du bien et du mal
qui était là aussi
donc qu'est-ce qu'on voit ici
on voit
donc là
on fait
un zooming
on va zoomer
dans la création
donc la description
du chapitre 1
c'est un résumé
quelque part
et la description
du chapitre 2
c'est plutôt
un déroulé
et ici nous sommes
en train de voir
la manière dont Dieu
a fait pousser
ses jardins particuliers
et la générosité
de Dieu
ici reflétée
l'environnement
parfait
très généreux
et donc c'est intéressant
Dieu a fait pousser
tous ses arbres
qui étaient agréables
à voir
et bons
à manger
et ensuite
on verra
un peu plus
sur la signification
de ces deux autres arbres
donc ce qu'on peut dire
pour l'instant
c'est qu'il a trouvé
a été créé
dans un état parfait
mais dans une condition
séminale
qu'est-ce qu'on veut dire
par là
si on prend
une sémence parfaite
nous savons
qu'elle a
les potentiels
et la capacité
de devenir
un arbre parfait
si nous sommes
en train de considérer
un embryon
dans un ventre maternel
nous savons
qu'il va se développer
envers un être humain
donc séminal
dans ce sens-là
dans le sens où
l'être humain
était dans une situation
de béatitude
déjà parfaite
mais qui pouvait
quand même
devenir encore
plus élevé
et donc
l'arbre
de la vie
vise à représenter
cette possibilité
à l'être humain
d'en préservant
sa soumission
volontaire
à Dieu
en faisant
confiance
à cet amour
de Dieu
cette générosité
dans les temps
de Dieu
selon les normes
sans raccourci
il arriverait
à une récompense
manger
de l'arbre
de la vie
et rendre
cette condition
de béatitude
éternelle
mais ici
il y avait encore
la possibilité
ou la possibilité
de tomber
d'échouer
et donc
il était parfait
mais Dieu
a établi
en faisant
usage
de ces éléments
c'est pas
comme si
attention
l'arbre
de la vie
avait un fruit
magique
ou l'arbre
de la connaissance
du bien
et du mal
avait un fruit
magique
nous allons
comprendre
quel était
ce pacte
que Dieu
a établi
avec l'homme
en faisant
usage
de ces éléments
en disant
je vous ai
tout donné
de manière
très généreuse
ne touchez
pas à ça
et vous
pourrez
toucher à ça
ok
et donc
on va comprendre
pourquoi
Dieu l'a fait
mais pour l'instant
c'est tout simplement
de remarquer
et reconnaître
quel environnement
généreux
la poussière
élevée
à image
des dieux
habitation
de l'esprit
des dieux
ok
notre élévation
dans un environnement
parfait
nous sommes devant
cette situation
glorieuse
description
de l'environnement
maintenant
verset 10
un fleuve
et ça c'est
très intéressant
car
jusqu'aujourd'hui
nous voyons encore
comment
les sociétés
se sont organisées
en grandes villes
et en général
proches des ressources
naturelles
comme la rivière
comme la Seine
par exemple
l'importance
de cette vie
cette provision divine
qui est affichée
par là
et les trésors
qui sont affichés
aussi
et donc la générosité
des dieux
de nous avoir
insérés
dans un environnement
très riche
très généreux
très glorieux
et donc
un fleuve
sortait d'Édans
pour arroser
les jardins
et dès là
s'est divisé
en quatre bras
les noms du premier
et donc à nouveau
des pays
des lieux géographiques
littérales
qui nous permettent
de tracer
là où était Édans
à cette époque
et donc
Psychon
c'est celui
qui entoure
tous les pays
d'Avlah
où se trouve l'or
l'or de ces pays
est pur
on y trouve aussi
le bdélium
et de la pierre
d'Onyx
le nom du second fleuve
est Guihon
c'est celui
qui entoure
tous les pays
des couches
et là c'est lié
à la notion
d'Éthiopie
donc le nom du troisième
c'est Hidekel
c'est celui
qui coule
de l'Orient
et de la Syrie
et le quatrième
fleuve
c'est l'Euphrate
et donc ici
nous sommes devant
un réalisme
historique
les dents
comme un lieu
réel
historique
parmi tout
en allégorie
les jardins
représentent
l'ordre parfait
des dieux
dans la création
avant la chute
et donc
qu'est-ce que ces rivières
peuvent représenter
en tant que
voilà
lieu géographique
et représentation symbolique
donc
ce sont des signes
concrets
dans les contextes
de la béatitude
de l'homme
dans l'état original
et cette provision divine
ces fleuves
qui sort
de l'édan
c'est-à-dire
c'est les lieux
que Dieu a établis
pour nous
et qui
donnent les directions
envers lesquelles
l'être humain doit
attention
reproduire
les paramètres
glorieux
car c'est Dieu lui-même
qui avait implanté
les jardins
et c'est toujours comme ça
comme si c'était un type
de lieu des dieux
avec son peuple
c'est comme une église
un sanctuaire
c'est une référence
pour les temples
et quand on arrivera
en Apocalypse
pour la Jérusalem céleste
on va retrouver
cette description
d'une rivière
qui coule
et qui va
se projeter
envers toutes les nations
donc l'être humain
a été appelé
à multiplier
à se multiplier
et à étendre
ou cultiver
et garder
ses jardins
c'est-à-dire
multiplier aussi
les paramètres des dieux
dans la gestion
de cet univers
et donc
c'est intéressant
car la division
de ces quatre rivières
pointe dans la direction
de toutes les nations
donc c'est un salut
qui va aussi
se promouvoir
par toutes les nations
tous les mondes
et donc on voit aussi
voilà plusieurs implications
dans ces passages
mais ça parle
de cet état
original
de l'homme
dans cette condition
de béatitude parfaite
avec richesse
et provision
donc les pierres
et les pays
sont ici
aussi révélés
avec des références
géographiques réelles
donc Kouch
qui est plutôt
l'Ethiopie
les pays
les pays d'Avila
et à Syrie
les pierres précieuses
aussi
qui veulent mettre
en évidence
toute cette générosité
des dieux
dans la beauté
des choses
qu'on peut réjouir
et donc
à nouveau
signification
glorieuse
être image des dieux
relation parfaite
avec dieux
avec l'homme
et avec l'environnement
avec la relation maritale
et surtout
cette notion
des relations avec Dieu
donc
à nouveau
une relation
avec Dieu
attention
une relation avec Dieu
d'intimité
privilégiée
d'être couvert
des bénédictions
vous êtes avec moi
mais une relation
qui pourrait encore
se développer
même envers Dieu
donc
il y a plusieurs implications
pour comprendre
les pactes
que Dieu va établir
donc un pacte
est toujours
une alliance établie
au moins
entre deux parties
ok
pas forcément
en ayant
pour point de départ
l'accord
des deux parties
donc c'est
la générosité
des dieux
et la grâce
voilà pourquoi
il y a une nuance
quand on appelle
ces pactes
les pactes
des œuvres
car
Dieu
est le souverain
gracieux
qui a enlevé
Adam
dans dehors
du jardin
il a mis
des dents
et c'est Dieu
lui-même
qui a donné
cette opportunité
à Adam
et à Eve
donc il faut
que ces pactes
soient quelque part
il ait une participation
volontaire
et c'est intéressant
car Dieu
va
insérer
dans l'être humain
dans la création
une loi
interne
donc d'être
un être moralement
parfait
comme était Adam
c'est de savoir
que les dix commandements
ok
qui peuvent résumer
toute la loi
mais ces valeurs
cette vie d'amour
envers Dieu
et envers les prochains
et envers le monde
c'est essentiellement ça
qui vise à communiquer
la moralité humaine
mais cette vie d'amour
est quelque chose
envers laquelle
nous vivons
ou nous vivions déjà
de manière très naturelle
c'est comme si on pourrait dire
presque dire ça
si on était livré
entre guillemets
ok
avec nuance
avec tact
à l'automatisme
ou aux instants parfaits
de notre propre nature
on allait toujours marcher
dans la direction
de l'obéissance
de l'amour
de la moralité parfaite
sauf qu'il est
ou moins créé
à l'image de Dieu
à l'origine
il avait
un arbitre parfait
et cet accord
avec Dieu
cette relation
ces pactes
a permis à l'homme
à donner une opportunité
à l'homme
en ayant
une loi externe
vous êtes avec moi
en ayant une loi externe
la possibilité
de manifester
une soumission
volontaire
une soumission volontaire
pendant un temps
suffisant
pour exprimer
la véracité
de cette soumission
volontaire
une soumission volontaire
exposée à un test
la tentation externe
de Satan
pour manifester
que cette soumission
était véritablement
authentique
et volontaire
et donc Dieu a donné
à l'homme
l'opportunité
d'exercer
son libre arbitre
original
dans la direction
de dire Dieu
oui
je t'adore
véritablement
oui je veux vivre
sous tes normes
qui sont mon bien
et ma récompense
c'est ce que je désire
le plus aujourd'hui
c'est de te connaître
encore plus
c'est de rendre
cette béatitude
éternelle
sans possibilité
de chute
et de réjouir
d'un niveau
de relation
encore plus noble
envers les créateurs
c'est grâce
dans le sens
où Dieu va établir
ses pactes
en donnant
à Adam
et à l'humanité
en Adam
cette possibilité
donc lisons les textes
les séquences
l'éternel Dieu
prit
l'homme
et les plaça
dans les jardins
des dents
pour les cultiver
et pour les garder
grâce
il sort
de dehors
les sanctuaires
des dieux
il sort du cas
d'être tout simplement
une créature
très élevée
à l'image des dieux
pour être
une créature
très élevée
à l'image des dieux
avec des paramètres
clairs
des comment
exercer son rôle
dans la plénitude
et avoir un rapport
encore plus intime
avec Dieu
pour cultiver
et pour les garder
les jardins
qui Dieu lui-même
avait plantés
et bien c'est 16
et c'est là
où j'espère
maximiser
sur votre compréhension
et l'importance
d'une interprétation
littérale
les poids
de chaque terme
l'éternel
nous avons étudié
les dix commandements
ensemble
c'est les noms
les plus sublimes
des dieux
les noms
les plus élevés
on revient
à la leçon
sur l'être
des dieux
et on comprend
que Dieu a choisi
dans sa condescendance
c'est-à-dire
c'est rébaissé
à notre langage
de nous donner
un nom
pour l'appeler
et les noms
qu'il a choisis
pour qu'on puisse
l'appeler
c'est ces noms
qui n'est même
pas prononçables
car très cohérent
avec un dieu
esprit
très cohérent
avec un dieu
incompréhensible
connaissable
mais au-delà
de nos définitions
toujours infiniment
plus excellent
infiniment plus puissant
et donc cet aspect
il y avait
et présente
la sainteté absolue
des dieux
les dieux élevés
les dieux
qui est éternel
je suis
ok
c'est la signification
de ces noms
c'est celui qui est
qui était
qui est
qui sera
et donc
attention
c'est lui
dès qui
la subsistance
de tous
dépend
en lui
nous avons
les mouvements
et l'être
donc
lorsque la Bible
nous dit
il y avait
vous voyez
comment on commence
à diminuer
nos mises en question
nos victimisations
c'est lui
qui nous a
introduits
dans cette relation
intime
avec lui
c'est les dieux
qui habitent
dans une lumière
inaccessible
et donc
l'éternel
les sang
celui
de qui nous dépendons
pour non seulement
exister
mais pour continuer
à exister
il a donné
une instruction
un ordre
donc
il
donna
cet ordre
donc c'est
Yahvé
qui donne l'ordre
mais c'est pas
qui est Yahvé
qu'est-ce que le texte dit
qu'est-ce que ça dit
dans vos textes
l'éternel
Dieu
et là nous sommes
devant les termes
Elohim
les dieux
tout-puissants
c'est quoi Elohim
regardez bien
la protection
l'éternel
Dieu
tout-puissant
Elohim veut dire
les dieux
tout-puissants
les seuls vrais dieux
contre tous
les idoles
bientôt
un serpent
apparaîtra
la possibilité
d'un idole
dans nos vies
elle va suggérer
!
qu'on soit
comme Dieu
idolâtrie
envers soi-même
!
mon importance
mais mettre
la place des dieux
et c'est pour ça
que dans la description
de la chute
des l'homme
nous allons remarquer
que tous les dix
commandements sont
franchis
en commençant par
l'idolâtrie
et ici c'est intéressant
car
l'éternel Dieu
donna
sa parole
il a donné
une instruction
autoritative
il a proclamé
par sa parole
un ordre
à cette créature
cette créature
dépend
de sa subsistance
et cette créature
les doit
son obéissance
et l'obéissance
à Dieu
et la subsistance
en Dieu
et la communion
avec Dieu
et être image
de Dieu
représente
l'expérience
la plus sublime
de l'humanité
si la liberté
c'est d'attendre
les plans potentiels
de notre existence
la vraie liberté
c'est de nous conformer
volontairement
c'est d'obéir
à ce que Dieu
a établi pour nous
comme normes
car c'est pour notre bien
pour notre bon fonctionnement
et donc à la racine
de ses péchés
nous allons voir
l'autonomie
mais c'est important
de voir
combien l'homme
est encadré ici
des privilèges
lui qui est appelé
ici
donc Dieu
donna cet ordre
à l'homme
vous voulez savoir
les termes originales
pour l'homme ici
c'est
Adama
Adam
car ça ne signifie pas
qu'il y ait l'homme
Ish
dans l'original hébraïque
c'est l'homme
voilà pourquoi
le nom de la femme
c'est
Isha
mais quand la Bible
parle d'Adam
elle est en train
de parler non seulement
d'un homme
comme la tête
de cette relation
mais elle est en train
de parler
de qui nous sommes
Adam signifie
littéralement
poussière
terre
donc
il y avait
et je suis dit
à la poussière
les tout puissant
dit à la poussière
vous étiez
de la poussière
je vous ai modelé
d'une manière glorieuse
avec un corps
glorieux
très complexe
je vous ai
doué
d'un nombre
infini
de plaisirs
même sensuels
qui vous pouvez réjouir
les plaisirs visuels
pour contempler
la beauté
de ma création
ou ma beauté
dans ma création
les plaisirs
du palais
pour goûter
tous ces fruits
avec une variabilité
infinie
les plaisirs
des relations
que vous auriez
entre vous
amitié
maritale
en contemplant
dans la beauté
de l'univers
quelques pistes
de la réjouissance
de la relation
avec moi
surtout
et donc
des poussières
à image
des dieux
mais jamais oublié
que nous sommes poussières
mais Adam ici
représente seulement
poussière
mais il représente aussi
la représentativité
de la race humaine
quand il dit ici
dans ses passages
Adam
plus tard il va dire
il a créé
la femme
donc Adam
va l'appeler
femme
car c'est de l'homme
qu'elle a été tirée
ish isha
masculin
féminin
mais ici
c'est la race humaine
l'ordre donné
à la race
à travers son représentant
et donc
cet état
de béatitude
est confirmé
car dans les versets
à 25
c'est notamment
les passages
avec lesquels
on va conclure
aujourd'hui
l'éternel Dieu dit
il n'est pas bon
que l'homme soit seul
je lui ferai
une aide
semblable à lui
donc cet ordre
a été donné
à Adam
comme représentant
de la race humaine
et dans les déroulés
de la création
il n'avait pas encore
fait
la femme
ici
il va faire la femme
et c'est très intéressant
aussi de voir
la liaison
entre
les données scientifiques
et la manière
dont Dieu va opérer
cette première chirurgie
comme on appelle
en français
avec sédation
anesthésie générale
donc ici
c'est intéressant
il n'est pas bon
que l'homme soit seul
donc c'est un constat
du vent
ça reste pour toujours
jusqu'à aujourd'hui
bien sûr
qu'il est dans une condition
de péché
il faut qu'on fasse attention
avec qui on sera
en relation
mais la réalité
c'est que Dieu
a fait la femme
pour compléter
quelque part
l'homme
pour complémenter
et cette distinction
entre les sexes
elle est très importante
pour qu'ensemble
on puisse refléter
au maximum
qu'il est possible
l'image des dieux
un dieu trinitaire
un dieu pluripersonnel
indivisible
mais c'est intéressant
aussi de remarquer
que Dieu
va déclarer
cette vérité
et va pousser
l'humanité
dans sa direction
donc je lui ferai
une aide
et donc d'ailleurs
c'est un terme
qui est très utilisé
pour s'appliquer
au Saint-Esprit
auxiliaire
ok
donc c'est en termes
de dignité
les deux ont une même mission
pour accomplir
selon leur rôle spécifique
ce qui va fortifier
l'ensemble de la relation
l'homme pour conduire
protéger
et la femme
pour être
cette aide
pour l'homme
et malheureusement
le plus on essaye
d'aller contre
ces principes
le plus on est en train
de s'autodétruire
et la réalité
c'est que
quand on verra
la chute en soi
on va comprendre
que
dans l'ADN
de la chute
il y a eu
le manque de respect
envers ces principes
l'homme n'a pas protégé
comme il devait
la femme
a pris la direction
pour donner les fruits
à l'homme
et les conséquences
de péché
vont aussi
dans la même direction
donc c'est une bataille
la bataille des sexes
qui commence ici
et donc l'éternel
forma de la terre
tous les animaux
des champs
et tous les oiseaux
du ciel
et il les fit venir
vers l'homme
pour voir comment
il l'appellerait
donc l'homme est là
en train d'accomplir
son rôle
pour organiser
classifier
faire de la biologie
de la science
et afin que tout être vivant
portât les noms
qui lui donneraient
l'homme
donc cette capacité
de l'homme
de reconnaître
l'ordre des dieux
dans la création
faire la science
et de reconnaître
ce que Dieu a fait
et on a cette capacité
de correspondre
cette intelligence
et l'homme donna
des noms
à tous les bétails
aux oiseaux du ciel
et à tous les animaux
des champs
et c'était un exercice
que Dieu était en train
de faire avec l'homme
pour qu'il arrive
à un constat lui-même
donc plan des dieux
parfait
plan A
souveraineté des dieux
il n'est pas bon
que l'homme soit seul
mais responsabilité
de l'homme
il va arriver
à cette même conclusion
il va interagir
avec ce monde
et va percevoir
que sans la femme
il n'est pas complet
et donc
mais pour l'homme
il ne trouva point
d'aide semblable à lui
alors l'éternel
Dieu fit tomber
en profond sommeil
sur l'homme
qui s'endormit
et il prit
une de ses côtés
donc l'esthésie générale
et aujourd'hui
la science montre
que l'un des mieux
lieux pour trouver
les cellules
souches
c'est dans la côte
ok
et donc il prend
de la côte
et donc il y a
beaucoup d'intentionnalité
en Dieu
pour qu'on soit
véritablement
une seule chair
dès l'origine
une même substance
et en même temps
en ayant les distinctions
qui Dieu a établies
pour qu'on soit
complémentaires
donc égalité
des valeurs
égalité
des capacités
des facultés
et distinction
en termes
des sexualités
et donc là
l'éternel
forma
une femme
de la côte
qu'il avait prise
de l'homme
et il l'amena
vers l'homme
et donc là
c'est intéressant
quelle est la première
réaction
donc les théologiens
sont tous d'accord
on est devant
un poème
et l'homme dit
voici cette fois
celle qui est
haut de mes eaux
chère de ma chère
on l'appellera
Isha
parce qu'elle a été
prise
de Ish
c'est pourquoi
l'homme
c'est un constat
divin
pour toujours
c'est pourquoi
l'homme
donc voilà
beaucoup de mariages
ne vont pas bien
car ils ne respectent
pas cette réalité
c'est pourquoi
l'homme
quittera son père
et sa mère
s'attachera à sa femme
et ils deviendront
une seule chair
l'homme
et la femme
étaient tous
les deux
nus
et ils
n'en avaient
point honte
ici c'est la conclusion
de l'état
des béatitudes
parfaites de l'homme
pourquoi on a fait
cet exercice
aujourd'hui
pour nous préparer
et nous protéger
de tout victimisme
c'est la condition
parfaite
des béatitudes
totales
il n'y a aucune excuse
pour ne pas
dire oui
et amène
à la volonté
de Dieu
pourvu
que toutes
les évidences
pointent dans la direction
d'un Dieu
infiniment
condescendant
et infiniment
généreux
envers nous
c'est impossible
de lire
ces passages
et de ne pas
être
complètement
étonné
submergé
même
dans les évidences
de la grâce
de Dieu
les grâces généreux
c'est presque
une protection
de la part
de Dieu
ne mangez pas
car le jour
où vous mangerez
certainement
vous allez mourir
donc avertissement
ne mangez pas
n'osez pas
désobéir
car obéissance
égale
la liberté
prospérité
générosité
préservation
et développement
de cette relation
avec Dieu
et le contraire
repose
complètement
sur notre responsabilité
et le contraire